[Musique]
c'était samedi dernier devant le
commissariat de besançon
une quinzaine de manifestants venus en
soutien à deux gilet jaune placé en
garde à vue
les manifestants demandent leur
libération certains propos dépasse le
registre des slogans habituels
les journalistes de radio vip sont
présents et filmé la scène un policier
sort et jette une grenade de
désencerclement les manifestants recul
mais une jeune femme semble ignoré
l'interdiction de manifester sur le
trottoir devant le commissariat
c'est à ce moment là que le policier l'a
gaz sans sommation nous avons retrouvé
cette jeune femme elle ne comprend pas
le geste du policier
moi j'étais tout seul je criais pas de
slogan je disais rien en fait donc
j'allais juste voir est ce que les gars
sortait ou pas est effectivement
maintenant pas je ne me sentais pas du
tout en tort d'être là surtout que j'ai
pas j'ai pas protesté outre mesure quand
on m'a demandé de partir
bien sûr que je trouve ça totalement
disproportionnée mais je suis pas
surprise en fait ça fait un an et demi
que c'est comme ça quelques secondes
plus tard la caméra enregistre aussi ce
cri des insultes homophobes et une
menace vient ici je vais rectifier la
gueule quelque chose de ce type là et
c'est à ce moment là que je vais tourner
la caméra parce que j'entends ça dans
mon casque donc je veux voir qui est le
policier qui dit ça je me pose même pas
la question si cinq manifestants et deux
policiers c'est un policier c'est clair
le policier sera vite rattrapé par ses
collègues qui le ramène à l'intérieur ni
la hiérarchie ni les syndicats de police
nous souhaité réagir
le préfet lui a demandé l'ouverture
d'une enquête administrative et fait
passer ce message aux médias
le préfet ne mésestime pas le climat de
tension qui pouvaient exister mais il va
de soi qu aucun manquement à la
déontologie ne sauraient être tolérés la
jeune femme gaz et a décidé de ne pas
porter plainte
[Musique]
bonjour